الناس
يأكلون أو يأكلون حرفيًا ، لذلك لا يستطيع أي شخص
دفع ثمن هواتف الطاقة الخاصة بهم ،
ولا يمكنهم تحمل أسعار المواد الغذائية التي لا يمكنهم
تحمل قروضهم العقارية ،
وأعتقد أنكم تعلمون أننا نعلم
أن ريشي سونا هي الأغنى  النائب في
البرلمان هو ليس ممثلًا
لأفراد الطبقة العاملة العاديين في هذا
البلد الذين يعانون أكثر من غيرهم
من حيث التأثير الوحشي
للسياسات
العامة وأعتقد بالنسبة لي ولدى الكثير من الناس
هنا هدف حقيقي واحد فقط وهو في
الذات.  -إثراء
أه إثراء المتبرعين
للحزب المحافظ
وأصدقائهم في مدينة لندن
أم وفي هذه الأثناء
هناك عمال في المملكة المتحدة يتم
تمثيلهم بألمهم وهي
مستويات منخفضة تاريخياً
[موسيقى]
لأن هناك نسبة ضخمة  أزمة تكلفة المعيشة
تضخم التضخم عند 12
راتبًا منخفضًا حقًا ولدينا
حكومة غير مستقرة للغاية أو
ثلاثة رؤساء وزراء في ثلاثة أشهر
أو تعلم أربعة أشهر ومن
الواضح تمامًا أن  تريد الحكومة الإلكترونية جعل
العاملين يدفعون ثمن الأزمة الاقتصادية ،
لذلك نحن هنا لرد
[الموسيقى] الأجنبية.
بريطانيا بلد غني جدًا ،
وليس من العدل أو المقبول أن
يعيش عشرات الملايين من الناس في
فقر الوقود  يعيشون في فقر حقيقي